kinderkram hallo mein name ist luca
meine lieben freunde ich würde lügen
würde ich sagen dass das heutige video
geistreich ist denn wir schauen uns den
rest von hilf mir schule
nein danke an meine letzte action sind
wir aber dem typen hier stehen geblieben
und ich frag mich da einfach noch mal
was man da vorlegen muss einen
professionellen businessplan ein wohl
würden falls sie meine ersten action
nicht gesehen habt könnt ihr euch hier
oben nochmal angucken aber ganz kurz
kurzfassung es geht darum dass duro 17
jahre alt ist die schule geschmissen hat
und jetzt nicht mit ihrem schmuck
selbstständig machen will
und das klappt nicht so gut kürzere auf
doro hat material für ihre armbänder
gekauft warum
ist dann roter teppich vor das ist
augenscheinlich kein laden wo ein roter
teppich vor gehört und besucht danach
ihre schwester im friseursalon ist ein
friseursalon die schauspielerische
leistung geht echt wieder gegen erdkern
also doro geht jetzt in diesem
friseursalon um ihre schwester tina
ihren schmuck zu präsentieren da bin ich
jetzt mal gespannt
50 euro
richtige schnapp adoro
meine ich nicht das gefällt jetzt schon
halb um aber auch nicht wirklich
s
die etwa 150 euro schmuck den sie dem
gekauften die sind nicht hochwertig wie
das dann so ich mag ihn fragt ob ich
hier direkt ein paar stückchen verkaufen
kann
jo
im friseursalon erscheint man ja auch
weil man schmuck kaufen will
richtig gut vorstellen die kommen hier
im salon werden mit namen aus den händen
reißen
weil wenn ich den kreis sein
bald wirst du stinkreich sein ich bin
auch stinkreich
nur ohne reich
nimmt man den kanal wenn ihr lust auf
mehr tolle witze unikate
ich hab mir das gesagt ja ein kreatives
ich sollte immer sagen dass du deine
schule da machen soll
sorry aber ich kann mir diese
schauspielerische leistung echt nicht
geben doro hat einen plan ausgeheckt um
ein weiteres geld für ihre
selbstgemachten armbänder zu kommen okay
sie wartet bis ihre eltern aus dem hause
wie die schon wieder geld klauen oder
was also doro mensch vielleicht solltest
du einfach mal selber was denn sein das
sind auch immer die besten gegenden wo
die da unterwegs und noch währenddessen
im friseurladen tine dekoriert die
design armbänder dass ich will echt
nichts gegen deinen traum einwänden doro
aber das sind halt einfach nicht selbst
gemachte armbänder das ist geschmack
deine schwester
[Musik]
halt irgendwie auch ein bisschen bleibe
ich kann mir das nicht wenig
die zogen das mitbekommt würde ein sehr
schlimmer als der andere
abnehmen kann es nicht wirklich alles
via mülheimer weg damit
alles ist weg damit könne die tore
gleich noch bitte daher spricht jetzt
auch in müll damit kinderkram aus wie so
frech zu sein deshalb ihr kreatives ich
gesagt und das hat immer recht doro will
sich die präsentation ihres schmucks im
laden anschauen die präsentation am
laden in der grünen tonne da katzen war
gucken aber den wunderschönen
präsentiert die hier ist mir zu jugend
hat die meine klientel sind schon
anspruchsvolle ältere damen
da einfach so eine kundin dieser laden
besitzen sagt eine kundin sind schon
ältere damen
er liebe ganzen volkes zugriff der gal
habe meine schwester noch ihre session
haben geschmack ich fände es noch einmal
beweisen meine kreativität keine grenzen
so kreativität kennt keine grenzen
uri darauf
um die perl anwender fertigen zu können
braucht sie geld nein greift hemmungslos
zu
nein
ich dachte das wäre ihr portemonnaie
gewesen was sie sich da gerade geholt
aber das ist das von karin
universum lieber bei nemo geblieben
warum will sie denn den den 16
also ganz kurz ist david erkennen da im
hintergrund story will stinkreich wert
und das mit ihrem schmuck erreichen
dafür cloud sie allerdings geld warum
klaus du da nicht einfach geld um reich
zu werden
warum muss dieses schmuck komponente
dazwischen sein begehren doch eine
straftat mir gut
aufgebracht haben sich selbstständig
machen und ein gewerbe anmelden
dafür braucht man allerdings ist ein
verständnis seinen eltern ja und ein
gewerbeschein viel von informationen
dazu bieten zb steuerberater
habe ich zum beispiel gemacht
mit youtube damals aber dori geld klauen
ist natürlich auch eine gute option
mutter gabi kümmert sich nichts ahnend
um den haushalt und macht eine
schreckliche entdeckung
dafür so
aber dass der der olaf sei ja sollte
sich herausstellen dass durch ihre
mutter wirklich geklaut hat dann ist sie
die längste zeit meine tochter gewesen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt da der familien segen schießtag
mal was hast du eigentlich wieder in
einer tüte
ach ich hab handys gekauft sorry
das ist die neue geschäftsidee und die
haben auch nur 180 euro gekostet so 30
euro schnapper viel und was ist mit
deiner schmuck dieser karriere ich
mensch da hat das kreative ich dann
plötzlich interveniert und gesagt das
machen jetzt nicht mehr machen jetzt
handy hüllen
das ist die geschäftsidee es gibt fast
gar keine handy hüllen bisher auf dem
markt
meinst du nicht das erst mal deine
arbeit machen sollte
schule ist so old school da sehe ich
auch handy hüllen
die braucht jeder
jeder hat ein handy ich auch
das ist ein pop socket es hier dran die
gibt village.de
apropos bodenkirchen übrigens ganz kurz
meine lieben freunde viele von euch
haben mich gefragt hey wann kommt denn
jetzt eigentlich das angekündigte merge
für den dezember kommt es nicht endlich
meinen ersten zwölfter ja die ist ja
nicht so ganz geschafft mit einem stoff
was neues probieren wollten aber es
kommt die tage abo diensten t shirt
tasten und eine mütze also merkt euch
kein richtiges datum weil ich weiss doch
dich richtig aber die tage hilft mir
gerade eine zweite kamera aufgebaut oder
was ist hier plötzlich sun power
angesagt direkt neben restaurant adana
richtige kleine kunden wurde gestohlen
sowas würde ich niemals tun so die dinge
macht sogar die ganz bestimmten sorgen
ich kann schon mal vorgehen aber mein
kreatives ich mache halt nie feierabend
[Musik]
ja
das ganz blöd ich würde so gern jetzt
auch feierabend machen aber mein
kreatives ich mache nie feierabend
handeln wenn mein neues denkt doch jeder
dass sich die gewinnerin noch viel mehr
material und viel mehr geld
und da geht man mal ab zum sabban
geliehenes reissdorf kölsch spielt sich
scheiße hier schon wieder in köln oder
was
das schönste an der seele hier geradezu
übrigens das kölner fußballstadion also
anscheinend spiel der ganze apparat
wirklich in köln
das stark aber doro geht jetzt hier in
dieser bar wo sie ist irgendwelchen
leuten an den tisch und sagt
beispielsweise und da will sie jetzt
ernsthaft ihr handy hülle verkaufen
ich meine klar ich gehe auch immer
abends in der bar um den handy
hinzukaufen ja gutes verkaufsargument
die hülle passt zu ihrem outfit trägt
einfach dein leben lang ab jetzt das
gleiche outfit auf jeder party bis dahin
wenn du die erhöhung von der den lärm zu
lesen
jetzt kommt der kellner weißt du ich
dass der kellner kommt jetzt eine hülle
kaufen das war ein guter plot wird wenn
du tore jetzt einfach so voll
durchstarten wird ihren handy hüllen und
plötzlich so jeff dieses überholt wo der
kellner tools wird er da arbeiten in dem
laden
allerdings sehe ich jetzt doch gerade
dass die folge zum glück vorbei ist
meine lieben freunde wenn euch meine
reaktion auf hilfen ihr schule nein
danke gefallen hat das kann einen daumen
runter video da schreibt mir und in die
kommentare auf welche folgen ergeben
sondern wenn noch kein abonnent von
meinem kanal seit dann würde ich auch
einfach dabei belassen
[Musik]